Speaker 1: I think you'll get a kick out of
this.
Maria Bartiromo on Fox News and Fox Business
has become one of the most weaponized brown
noser for everything, Trump and everything
A. Biden.
She used to be a pretty serious financial
journalist when I was growing up and started
following the stock market.
She was reporting from the floor of the New
York Stock Exchange and doing really good
interviews of Fortune 500 CEOs, and she has
become nothing but a Trump brown noser and
a right wing extremist, at least as far as
her on on screen presentation, and she was
interviewing House Minority Leader Kevin McCarthy.
No moderate centrist by any stretch of the
imagination.
I mean, McCarthy is a right wing loon, and
she brings up impeaching Biden.
Like, I would definitely impeach Biden if
you take control of the House and McCarthy
doesn't go for it.
As much as McCarthy would love to impeach
Biden if he thought he could get away with
it, and if he thought that it would be good
politically, even McCarthy seems to be playing
a little bit of a whoa, whoa.
Whoa, let's slow down for a second here, Maria.
This is fascinating to see.
Let's take a look.
Speaker 4: I spoke with one of your colleagues
on Friday on FOX Business Greg Murphy, and
he told me that all of the things that he
is seeing from President Biden are impeachable.
But the Congress is worried about what,
Speaker 1: what, what things are those?
I mean, this is just out of this world not
Speaker 4: reaching him because they're not
so confident about his number two.
Here's Craig Murphy.
I want to get your reaction to this watch,
Speaker 1: by the way.
Imagine thinking, Hey, you know what?
We could impeach and remove Biden, but then
Kamala becomes the president, and that's not
good.
So we're not going to impeach.
What?
What are you talking about?
Speaker 2: I think there's going to be plenty
of foot.
There's plenty.
If you look at Afghanistan, you look at the
border crisis, you look at so many of these
different things.
The sad thing is, Maria, look at who's number
to look at who's number two.
Speaker 1: I think number and think about
that.
Impeach Biden for getting out of Afghanistan,
which Trump was scheduled to do if he had
won and remained president.
What would you impeachable impeach Biden because
of the situation at the border, which is essentially
unchanged from when Trump was president?
What are these people talking about?
And the viewers don't know.
They just have no idea.
They're like, Oh yeah, yeah, it sounds right.
Speaker 2: Who is worse than no one?
So this is the potato predicament that we're
in.
But these offenses that this president has
done against the heart and soul of this country,
against law and order, I think stands are
grounds for impeachable offenses.
Speaker 4: Congressman, what about that?
Will you move to impeach President Biden?
Speaker 2: But one thing we learned that the
Democrats did is they used impeachment for
political reason, we believe in the rule of
law.
We're not going to pick and choose just because
somebody has power.
We're going to uphold the law at any time.
If someone breaks the law and the ramification
comes impeachment, we would move towards that,
but we're not going to use it for political
purposes.
Our focus is going to be securing our border,
making us energy independent, bringing these
prices down, making our schools safe and our
streets again and holding this administration
accountable.
And we will take the facts to wherever the
facts go, because America has been through
too much anyway.
Speaker 1: So I don't believe a word he's
saying.
And what I mean by that is McCarthy would
be right there impeaching Biden, for sure.
If he thought it would help him politically.
But right now, he knows it's too crazy, crazy
for the minority leader of the House to just
come out and say our plan is to impeach Joe
Biden now as a counterpoint.
Marjorie Taylor Greene is saying that and
the things she's saying are way crazier than
the things even Maria Bartiromo is saying.
As crazy as impeaching Biden for getting out
of Afghanistan would be.
Listen to what Marjorie Taylor Greene has
planned.
If Republicans take control of the House
Speaker 4: in the congressional record that
we can now expose on that laptop.
Here's what we do after that, right?
We need to impeach Kamala Harris.
Speaker 1: What why can't they get Kamala
Harris his name correct?
At this point at, you know, in all honesty,
do you think they're doing it on purpose that
day?
It's a subtle dig.
I mean, you know, like, for example, you know,
I say Tulsi Gabbard and I admit it's a completely
juvenile dig.
I think she's a completely unserious person.
And the idea that I can't even be bothered
to learn her name, I find it funny when it
comes to Kamala.
Do you think they're doing it on purpose?
Do you think they genuinely can't learn Kamala
Harris name?
Like, what do you what do you think is behind
it?
Speaker 4: Because you can't encourage and
promote raised money for criminal rioters
and expect to serve the interest of the people,
the great people in the United States.
That is that is a conflict of interest.
Speaker 1: She is not kidding.
There is a group within the Republican Party.
And it may be the mainstream of the Republican
Party.
It remains to be seen in the sense of we'll
see who gets behind it if and when they take
control of the house.
There is a group that is determined to impeach
Joe Biden.
How do we know?
Well, some of them have already written up
articles of impeachment.
They don't go anywhere because Republicans
don't control the House.
But Lauren Boebert has written up articles
of impeachment.
Marjorie Taylor Greene has, for now, people
like Kevin McCarthy are just holding short.
They're saying, Well, we will impeach if that's
what should happen.
But he's not committing to an impeachment.
They're going to do it.
And this is yet another reason why if Republicans
do take control of the House, or imagine if
they take control of both the House and Senate
in November, it is going to be obstruction
city.
Biden will get nothing else done, and there
may be an impeachment trial.
To serve as a distraction during the second
two years, this the third and fourth years,
the second half of Joe Joe Biden's first term
as president.
They're going to do it when they're telling
us they're going to do it, and I believe that
they're going to do it and it's going to be
a nightmare.